الكاريزما السياسيه وفقه كثيرين ادت لتفوق
رجب طيب اردوغان على منافسه الرئيسي كمال
كلتش وتحديا امال المعارضه بالفوز الكبير
ورغم امال رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري بتحقيق
مفاجاه بجوله الاعاده حددت صحيفه فاينل
تايمز البريطانيه العقبات الجاثمه امامه
بثلاثه اولها ارهاق الناخبين المعارضين
وفقدانهم للحافز بعد نتائج كانت اسوا من
المتوقع اما ثاني التحديات فمن داخل
المعارضه اي التشكيك بان كيله هو المنافس
المناسب لمواجهه اردوغان فكل
حزب الشعب الجمهوري لثلاثه عشر عاما دون
ان ينتصر في اي انتخابات تشريعيه او حتى
رئاسيه لكن العقبه الاهم تتمثل بالحصول
على اصوات المرشحه الرئاسي القومي سنان
اوغان الذي حصد اكثر من 5% من اصوات
الناخبين في الجوله الاولى لكن ميله
لاردوغان اكثر ترجيحا الى ان خبراء سبقوا
جوله الاعاده بالتاكيد ان المشهد السياسي
التركي سيظل دون تغيير تقريبا
والله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات